we have any guidelines
this man has acute myelogenous leukemia
he is flown from his home in Denver to
the US Public Health Service Hospital in
Baltimore or new treatment with drugs I
was interested to know so that I could
do some personal planning yes along
these lines
I think this is very important for you
to take care of your own make sure your
house is in order
sure I was wondering what the
possibilities of a remission would be
with the drugs which you have mentioned
and along with remission would last with
our present experience we are getting
remissions at somewhat over one-third
and forty percent of patients and it is
true that when you do reach remission
status you are clinically and
hematological a normal there's no
evidence leukemia whatsoever now our big
problem is we are just stymied or unable
to maintain their emission too long
exactly case-to-case how predict how
long it will last
I can't do we do have some patients that
have been in remission well over a year
year and a half two years unless is the
substantial and but there are many many
patients who are only in remission one
or two months but of course let's say we
do use Donna Meissen we get a remission
and in the event that relapse does occur
you can use cytosine arabinose i in fact
we have other drugs after that one of
the benefits of being here at least is
that there are always new things on the
horizon that are here if a rule does
occur you have a good chance of
participating in that breakthrough here
we felt that in medical research there
is always hope for a breakthrough can
science find a drug to cure cancer
Kassar has been treated for some time
many of the cancers which form solid
tumors can be treated with surgery if
all the cancerous tissue is removed the
patient is cured the same is true of
radiation treatments sure depends upon
destruction of all the cancerous tissue
but sometimes the cancer spreads to
other parts of the body leukemia or
cancer of the blood is of course all
over the body in such cases the ideal
therapy would be a chemical which could
spread through the body and kill every
cancer cell for more than a decade there
is been a national program to find and
test anti-cancer drugs administered and
supported in great part by the National
Cancer Institute at Bethesda Maryland
the search is worldwide there are 10
million natural products that might
contain an anti-cancer compound near
Nairobi botanists gather leaves and the
bark of trees to process and test
against cancer in the shallow waters of
the Caribbean marine biologists collect
invertebrates like the West Indian
starfish
as part of the nationwide cancer
chemotherapy program they process and
test the starfish to find out whether it
might contain drug materials effective
against leukemias and solid tumors the
search goes on in North Carolina with
the gathering of plants and grasses by
botanists with the United States
Department of Agriculture any of these
could contain a valuable anti-cancer
agent to test these materials for
anti-cancer activity researchers might
screen them in 1,000 animal tumors
against 100 different human cancers how
can scientists determine what chemicals
are in these dried twigs
how can such chemicals be tested safely
in human beings with cancer the unknown
material sent in from the field is first
processed and tested for anti-cancer
capability in two so-called
animal models laboratory mice with a
known leukemia and rats with a known
tumor these two types of cancer catch
almost all actives if the compound is an
active it will reduce the tumor mass as
compared with the tumor in a rat that
got no compound but if the compound
kills tumor cells in a rat it is likely
to kill some normal cells too to measure
these adverse effects researchers
administer the compound to monkeys after
a suitable period they remove a sample
of the monkeys blood and subjected to a
series of tests that revealed the
effects of the unknown chemical on
normal blood cells for example the
caligula ssin time other tests show
other effects on the blood and on the
kidney the liver and spleen and
particularly on the bone marrow where
red corpuscles and white blood cells are
manufactured such tests indicate the
chemicals toxicity and helped define a
safe dose for the test in human beings
if a compound shows anti-cancer activity
other researchers try to determine what
it is composed of by means of column
chromatography and many other tests the
chemical compounds flowing down this
column stratified in this way because of
their unique molecular properties may
turn out to be potent anti-cancer agents
more likely they will not only about one
agent in 15,000 tested as proven
effective chemists also attempt to
synthesize new anti-cancer agents this
is a plastic model enlarged thousands of
times of a molecule essential to the
reproductive process in all cells to
produce one effective drug researchers
over many months removed one of the
hydrogen's and put a fluorine in its
place producing an antagonist that is
absorbed by the cell as if it were the
real thing then destroys it in the last
test a safe and effective dose for human
beings is determined by preclinical
pharmacologists
the moment of truth in the long search
is the clinical trial will believes and
grasses from Nairobi or the compound
synthesized in a laboratory make a drug
to control cancer in human beings this
is a regular staff conference in the
clinical Center at Bethesda case
histories of patients on trial programs
are presented in this instance the first
patient on a new drug then the doctors
discuss the implications of their
findings for the nationwide research
program a doctor wonders where the first
phase of drug study should be done one
study should be done on patients there
is no established therapy that would
benefit those you get phase one
information saying a solid tumor and you
get some idea what the toxicity but you
really is that going to applying the
patient a with you team you know CML
plastic crisis I thought you would have
evaluated the drug under relatively
clean conditions it gets hotter date I
think what involves the Maryland the
disease involves the memorable much
research is being done on the size of
the dose large single doses killed
cancer cells effectively but they also
kill some normal cells so doctors must
balance dosage against adverse side
effects had one patient stood on 801
which is twice the story in what he
tolerated the single dose debate a new
program quite well he left the hospital
the second set of good function tests
are going to be done this week like we
haven't heard from you I ventured
feeling quite well combinations of four
drugs are effective but it has been
difficult to follow up certain four drug
programs with some of the new drugs such
as cytosine or upon aside where phase
one study should be done because we
noticed when we first started using
cytosine or Aventine it was after the
for drug combination has two people
relapsed and we saw a significant number
of patients was a transient was often
quite severe hepatic damage with
cytosine around the side were very
concerned about it other institutions
were starting right off with cytosine
identified in AML and some others and I
think this was probably for the same
reason people that we had an
intermission average time of nine months
and that time stay God
deciding around inside of this more
sensitive truck same thing applies is
reaction with a poor drug company we saw
a higher degree of paddock dysfunction
as we invest in the same drugs as we did
in the primary infection with some
cancers adversely affect the bone marrow
where red corpuscles and white blood
cells are produced by studying a sample
of the bone marrow doctors can follow
the evolution of the disease and the
effects of different drug programs
cytogenetic though we have not a feed
America to take a marrow sample the
doctor carefully anesthetize is the
local area then insert the needle
through the flesh into the end of the
bone
and on into the marrow
a syringe withdraws a small sample of
the marrow
this is placed on microscope slides then
examined
this Merrill sample from a patient with
acute leukemia is hypercellular
saturated with malignant cells at a
larger magnification the malignant cells
called blasts show an unusually large
nucleus after two courses of treatment
with drugs a marrow sample might show
fewer blasts and increasing numbers of
normal white cells a sign of improvement
later in remission when the disease is
under control there will be only 5%
blasts but the peripheral blood the
blood that is flowing through the body
is also a good indicator of the state of
the patient's disease and the efficacy
of treatment a sample of the patients
blood is diluted and placed on a counter
the dials reveal the number of blood
cells in a measured sample a symptom of
leukemia is an excessive number of
abnormal white blood cells ineffective
against invading microorganisms cancer
research needs many blood donors
leukemia for example sometimes reduces
the number of blood platelets the tiny
cells that maintain the integrity of
blood vessel walls bleeding may result
but platelets can be replaced by
transfusion all blood is removed
centrifuge to bring down the heavier red
cells and placed on an extractor that
squeezes the platelet-rich plasma
off the top of the sample or transfusion
into the patient in this case the son of
the donor since both the drug and the
cancer may affect the body's ability to
resist invading microorganisms many
patients die of infection or protection
some patients are placed in a plastic
bubble that completely surrounds them at
all times doctors conduct routine
examinations even though they are
completely cut off from the patient only
filtered air and aseptic materials enter
this sterile private world yet doctors
can perform bone marrow and other
operations
this laminar flow room now under test at
Bethesda may someday replace the plastic
bubble it will repel microorganisms by
continually blowing fresh filtered air
across the patient doctors and visitors
will enter and remain downstream if the
experimental drug cannot control the
number of white blood cells doctors use
the continuous flow blood cell separator
shown at the MD Anderson hospital and
tumor Institute in Houston the machine
draws whole blood from one arm pumps it
through carefully sterilized tubes to a
weight-sensitive buffer bag which
controls the pump and sends it to a
centrifuge which is similar to a cream
separator because of the different
densities of white cells red cells and
other blood elements they separate at
different points along the radius of the
disc on what it sells are shunted aside
and the rest returned to the patient
if a drug is successful against one kind
of cancer in Phase one it is tested
against other kinds then it is sent for
further tests to many hospitals around
the country does anyone know what the
liver toxicity has been with the first
in Brazil since that's been tried pretty
extensively now and good work there has
not really been much mentioned me liver
toxicity in the patients that have
extended that been evaluated after
therapy so I would assume although I
don't know directly that we haven't used
the older here there really isn't any
all we know there are the questions
Angele balancing dosage against toxicity
I would agree with you very much on that
now the thing is one of the reasons if
we are happy with this type of schedule
it is giving one dose and then waiting
to see recovery is that it gives us time
to back off and those things let's talk
to us the abate and I think it's
probably the safest way to start out
giving a drug and finally the question
of an adequate trial for each drug what
would be in this particularly yeah
well I think that the I would think that
in this particular patient if you if the
physicians in charge think it's to
deliver to deliver then I suspect and
liver toxicity through the drug and say
well we had to stop because of liver
toxicity but my only impression is not
so sure if we can distribute evolved and
would feel that the risk involved giving
him said half dose not would not be that
great but still allow us to see if this
drug isn't going to be useful we're
hoping that in political research the
doctor is concerned not just with a drug
and an effective schedule of
administration but with a whole patient
and his disease she's got one dose one
exactly one a week ago and she's
scheduled for her second dose today your
heart laughing oh never had a murmur as
a child
have you found anything her cardiac
status is completely normal as far as we
can tell but the doctor always returns
to the key questions which dosage has
worked which schedule has been most
effective or 25,000 but in terms of
concentration it's not too different she
didn't respond an oil flex minimizes on
one occasion her tire became completely
negative that is zero and subsequently
came back up again though this was on
actinomycin D in the last few months
she's received three or four courses of
methotrexate and infusion type and her
tires have gone down and from back up
but our general courses remained
essentially unchanged and in the light
of the natural course of this disease
it's fair to say that the methotrexate
has been somewhat effective because I
decide in your mind whether she was
really drug resistant or just perhaps in
dosage
I think as you will I think it's
difficult to say if we could give the
methotrexate more often perhaps we might
have a better effect
what's been the limiting factor the
limiting factor has been toxicity
related primarily to alterations in your
mouth and which have been quite severe
although not complicated by infection so
far he had alterations anywhere else
because methotrexate no not that we know
of gotten I didn't have a rash on her
skin which I couldn't say was clearly
related to methotrexate but may have
been she has not had it with each dose
she's tolerated if therapy actually
quite well if you notice anything when
you got your first dose of Donna bison
no I was really surprised like it leaves
a party after well gonna be a long
postage schedule had some good luck with
it and that's an I'd love mention
the guiding principles in all good
clinical research is concern for the
patient we don't quite as relaxed as you
are like how's the back doing and the
legs my legs hurt they do hurt yeah yeah
I'm back don't bother me I wonder if you
can roll over on your side which will
force the window we just want to feel
good
I want you to tell me mr. Simpson that
this win and if this hurts you at all
that tender no not yet
that tender no that's a little bit how
about over here no over here no right
here well I believe it's a little bit
right there here no here no little bit
right there that's that's Indian thing
right there a lot or a little bit no
just a little cheaper to me I wonder if
he would get reproducing
well calm those we finding us the
results on the x-rays and there does
seem to be something that may well be
called your pain down the leg but it's
in this area we're going to talk with
the radiotherapy people today see if
they can help us I will let you know
later on today today I think so when we
get to see you your next course that
came out there and starts next week next
week yeah
depending on what your blood count shows
could be they think they can help you
with that combined - okay
that's doing yeah Thank You fairy bye
handsome I didn't next oh yeah well
everything else you know has so we can
get this paint under everything okay
where has the National Cancer Institute
program led in advanced forms of
Hodgkin's disease a for drug treatment
produced complete remissions
or temporary disappearance of all
evidence of cancer in twice as many
patients as ordinarily achieve remission
with single drugs a group of 35 children
with acute leukemia were treated
intermittently with massive doses of
four drugs the median survival of these
children was three years compared with a
three-month survival of leukemic
children twenty years ago the story of
cancer drug research will continue next
week in part two the battle in the cell
or further information on cancer
chemotherapy right for a free booklet
drugs versus cancer available from the
research information branch National
Cancer Institute Bethesda Maryland
these are normal human cells from
prosthetic tissue living in a laboratory
dish
they were filmed through a microscope
that magnifies them 270 times these are
the same kind of human cells from
prosthetic tissue grown and filmed in
the same way but they are cancer cells
the cells normal and cancer differ in
ways not yet fully understood it is the
task of the cancer team of therapists
the scientist who hopes to control
cancer through the use of drugs to
exploit those differences so that a drug
can kill all of these cells without
killing more than a few of these in the
same human being
cancer has been treated successfully for
some time by surgery in which the
malignant tissue is removed and by
radiation in which it is destroyed by
cobalt and x-rays but sometimes cancer
spreads to other parts of the body even
as the local area is being treated
successfully in such cases new hope may
be offered by chemotherapy the use of
drug treatment you had you had surgery
to everyone have X right there
when was it really Frank and that was
for a local the crisis in your disease I
think and then did that hold it under
control
have you ever received any other therapy
very often patients for breast cancer
yet estrogen therapy corticosteroids
cortisone it was guys I can't dry up
also that is yes these are our calls as
those hormones that control cancer
breast cancer did this help yes when I
was taking with two or three it helps
they vent and I had a stop inside
starting life here
basically the problem with your disease
is that you did have localized disease
and you received surgery and then for a
local recurrence radiotherapy and I
think now problem is that the disease is
just too far too widespread
could be controlled by any of these
local needs where is dr. hunter tell you
that you had to see eventually what
happens in cancer exactly do have to use
drugs even after local therapy and after
hormonal therapy you did have the mental
therapy and the disease has progressed
to the point where your doctor didn't
feel that you should go to a center that
is more concerned that has more
experience in drug treatment oh Allah
granted were you happy about longing or
we how did this strike you when we've
discussed this with you
we're kind of shocked me a little bit
and I made up my mind that would he
advised me it was best thing for me to
do he said if I couldn't get in there
I'll be very lucky
hmm
for more than a decade the National
Cancer Institute has guided and
supported a large national program of
cancer chemotherapy scientists are
studying the whole patient the effects
of many kinds of drugs on the course of
his disease and on the inner workings of
cancer cells a cell is visible to the
human eye only through a microscope
nevertheless it is the building block of
which all tissue is made when new tissue
is needed the cell divides each
so-called mother producing two daughters
exactly like the mother each daughter
produces two more daughters also the
same when no more tissue is needed the
doubling stops halted by an unknown
biological signal the cancer cell and
all its daughter cells do not receive or
do not obey the signal they keep
multiplying far beyond what the body can
tolerate this relentless growth of
non-functional cells can lead to illness
and death the experimental evidence of
this is startling blood is withdrawn
from the abdomen of a mouse with
leukemia
it is diluted and the cells are
countered under a microscope they are
diluted and counted again until any
given drop is likely to contain only one
or two leukemic cells with this
instrument called a micro manipulator
scientists at Southern Research
Institute in Birmingham today can
isolate a single living leukemic cell
using a hair like tube the technician
places several drops of the diluted
material on a glass slide the slide is
turned over so the drops are hanging
from the lower surface and is placed
under a microscope the technician
locates a single drop
he carefully moves a pipette a delicate
glass tube up under the slide and with
hydraulically operated controls that
scale down his movements he inserts it
into the droplet
and withdraws the leukemic cell
the cell is transferred to a hypodermic
syringe a single cancer cell it is
injected into a normal healthy Mouse
within eight days there is a noticeable
abdominal swelling evidence of the
growth of leukemic cells the cancer
cells continue to increase each mother
producing two daughters each daughter
producing two more daughters until after
ten days the swelling in the abdomen is
pronounced by the 19th day the single
cancer cell will have proliferated to
more than 1 billion cells enough to kill
the animal but certain chemicals can
stop this cancerous growth in this
laboratory culture we see mouse leukemia
cells dividing with cleavage as shown in
the center of the screen completed after
the usual length of time but when a drug
is added the reproductive cycle of the
cells is violently disrupted the cell in
the center of the culture stays at
metaphase an intermediate stage in the
division process an unusually long time
cleavage is irregular daughter cells are
of unusual size and do not survive very
long human cancer cells are also
affected by drugs these cancer cells in
a laboratory dish are dividing in the
usual way as shown at far right
if an alkaloid from the periwinkle plant
is added cells proceed to the second
phase of the cycle as seen in the
rounded cells but cannot go beyond this
phase mother cells cannot produce
daughters stopping the relentless
reproduction that characterizes the
growth of cancer cells but it has been
found that a given dose of a given
anti-cancer drug destroys only a certain
percentage of the cells in a living
animal regardless of the absolute number
of cancer cells
the percentage destroyed by the same
sized ghost will always be the same
suppose a given type of cancer cells
doubles approximately every 12 hours
once every 24 hours we administer a drug
which kills 60% of the cancer cells
present again the remaining cancer cells
double and again we kill 60%
we have slowed them down but they are
increasing faster than we are killing
them and they will eventually increase
in mass or number to the point where
they kill the animal we can increase the
doses so that we are killing the cancer
cells faster than they can multiply but
anti-cancer agents also affect normal
cells if the dose is too large and if
too many normal cells are killed while
we are destroying the cancer cells the
animal may sicken and die is it possible
to kill large numbers of cancer cells
with drugs without killing too many
normal cells
these normal mice are injected with an
anti-cancer drug called cyclosporine 24
hours later the femur or upper leg bone
of the mouse is removed the ends clipped
and the bone marrow the sight of blood
forming stem cells is washed out and
diluted in a laboratory solution
to find out how the drug has affected
the merrill and its ability to produce
cells the technician injects the diluted
marrow into a mouse whose stem cells
have been destroyed ten days later after
the injected marrow cells have had a
chance to multiply the animals spleen is
removed and fixed in Bouin solution
marrow cells form nodules on the spleen
the number of nodules in this case a
dozen or so indicates the number of
cells surviving a measure of the effects
of the original anti-cancer agent on the
normal cell but what does the agent do
to cancer cells a lymphoma bearing Mouse
is injected and 24 hours later it's bone
marrow is removed again following the
same procedure used with the normal
Mouse the marrow is diluted and injected
into the tail of a mouse which will
serve as a kind of incubator or culture
dish for the marrow cells 8 days later
the spleen of the cancer Mouse is
removed again the nodules are counted an
indication this time of the rate of
survival of cancer cells after drug
treatment to get good data 66 such
experiments were conducted at the
Ontario Cancer Institute each one
involving more than 100 mice
when the results were plotted the curve
showing the percent survival of normal
cells as against increasing drug dosage
looked like this the curve indicating
percent survival of cancer cells with
increased drug dosage looked like this
there is no question that some drugs
kill many more cancer cells than normal
cells in the same living organism and
that kill ratios vary with dosage so
dose amount as well as timing is
important in the battle in the cell but
can we further improve this ratio the
ratio of cancer cell killed to normal
cell kill just within the past couple of
years a new approach to this problem has
been developed based upon close
observation of the life cycle of the
cell in addition to the phase during
which the cell divides there are several
other cycle phases generally cells
appear to rest in one phase synthesize
genetic material in another rest again
then divide but timing is crucial how
can we find the length of each phase in
the life cycle of a cancer cell at
Southern Research Institute researchers
use a radioactive material that is
absorbed into cancer cells during the S
phase
they injected into laboratory mice with
the solid tumor designated sarcoma 180
let the tumor grow then remove it in
this tumor how many cells have taken up
the radioactive material
how many have passed through the S phase
and on into mitosis or cell division
after mincing the tumor the technician
suspended in a measured amount of saline
solution and carefully breaks down the
tumour tissue in a laboratory
homogenizer
then the technician strains the mixture
to remove large clumps of tissue
and places the liquid containing
radioactive cancer cells into a
centrifuge later the packed cells are
treated in other ways and are placed on
glass slides each carefully marked for
future identification
to find out how many cells are
radioactive and thus have passed through
the s-phase the slide is converted into
a kind of photographic plate it is
coated with emulsion and left in a dark
room for six weeks
to count the cells that have absorbed
the radioactive material the researcher
not only examines all portions of the
slide under a microscope but also
studies it on closed-circuit television
cells containing radioactive material
are identified by the dark spots on the
emulsion on this slide over 3000 cells
were studied and counted from this
experiment the researchers determined
that the lifecycle of a sarcoma 180 cell
is about thirteen and a half hours and
that the S phase lasts almost eight
hours important data in determining the
best time to administer drugs that kill
during the S phase of the thousands of
drugs tested some apparently kill only
during the S phase of the life cycle yet
their kill ratio is good of the
thousands tested some were found to kill
throughout the lifecycle and they also
can give good cancer cell to normal cell
kill ratios but when these different
kinds of drugs are combined they can
give much better kill ratios much
experimentation involves drug schedules
experimenters at Southern Research
Institute have developed ways to
administer drug steadily over long
periods of time to mice with different
kinds of cancer
a tube is inserted enter peritoneal e
and the mouse is allowed to run into his
small chamber along with a dozen or so
of his cousins the experimental drug is
drawn into a special syringe
and the syringe is mounted on a rack one
syringe for each mouse
other syringes are filled with harmless
saline solution for administration to a
group of control mice they will be
watched to see whether the apparatus
rather than the drug affects them in any
way
now each syringe is adjusted precisely
to ensure administration of a carefully
measured amount of drug
the mice and their stalls are given a
final check a timer is started and the
drug is fed through the tubes at a
constant rate in this apparatus the drug
can be made eventually to hit every cell
in a cancer mass no matter when or how
long it is susceptible to the drug but
scientists thought it might be better to
treat the animal with a single stronger
dose followed by other doses at a later
time perhaps giving the normal cells
more time to recover from drug damage
before they are treated again not long
ago southern Research Institute tested
cytosine a rabbit aside in a batch of
mice with leukemia
in the first experiment they gave a
measured dose of drug to hundreds of
animals once each day for a period of 15
days some mice were used as controls
they got no drug
at the end of the experiment the control
mice died as predicted on the basis of
the growing knowledge of cell kinetics
the experimental mice those that got the
drug lived much longer although all
eventually died when the results were
averaged out it was determined that the
daily dosage had increased the lifespan
of the experimental mice substantially
although none were cured but by simply
changing the timing of the
administration the scientists got
dramatically different results they used
the same kind of mice mice which had
been in bred for generations to enhance
their similarity for laboratory purposes
and the same drug cytosine aravane aside
and essentially the same size dose but
instead of administering the drug once a
day they administered it every three
hours around the clock at four-day
intervals
control mice again got no drug and again
they died according to estimates based
on cell kinetics the experimental mice
those that got the drug on the new
schedule continued to live happily
some laboratory animals can be cured of
cancer but human beings are a far cry
from laboratory animals can drugs be
found or designed that will destroy the
billions of cancer cells that sometimes
spread through human beings a computer
program developed at the National Cancer
Institute may help find the answer into
the computer are fed assumptions about
the generation time of a given cancer
cell the duration of the S phase and the
fractional cell kill of a given drug in
seconds the computer can reveal among
other things the number of cells
remaining at the end of the dose period
with such information drug programs can
be tailored for individual patients
other progress is being made the animal
model for testing drug activity against
cancer is giving good biological
information that has a direct bearing on
the disease in man although enormous
problems remain there is hope that
continued research will lead to even
greater life expectancy for even more
patients
for further information on cancer
chemotherapy write for a free booklet
drugs versus cancer available from the
research information branch National
Cancer Institute Bethesda Maryland
you